ha sido un tono incluso más áspero de lo
que se había pronosticado baiden
prometió que sería duro y además eeuu
aprobó en las vísperas las sanciones a
funcionarios chinos por la reciente
reforma electoral así que china acudió a
alaska preparado para intercambio de
golpes y reproches eeuu en su primera
intervención afeó a china sus políticas
en xinjiang
hong kong y taiwán asuntos que son
sagrados para china beijing por su parte
acusó a eeuu de utilizar su poderío
económico y militar para intentar
imponer su voluntad en todo el mundo
ambos países se acusaron mutuamente de
utilizar un tono arrogante y de romper
los protocolos pactados ha sido un
intercambio agrio pero que contentará a
ambas audiencias internas a china le
servirá para mostrar a su pueblo que ya
es capaz de abofetear eeuu a domicilio
mientras que a bailén le servirá para
refutar la teoría que asegura que es un
tibio y que solo trump era capaz de
poner en cintura a china las
conversaciones ya sin focos han
continuado y según fuentes
periodísticas han sido productivas la
cumbre terminará mañana y si no hay
cambio de última hora lo hará sin
declaración conjunta para subrayar
todavía más las diferencias que separan
ambos países